hey everybody Sean McGuinness here
alongside Danny Isaac the executive
producer on Kinect Sports rivals and
Danny you're about to show me some of
the ways that you guys are using the the
new Kinect hardware for the Xbox one - I
guess improve the experience over a
previous Kinect sport
yeah absolutely so will that show you
here is our champion scanning technology
it's a quick and easy way to get you
your likeness and you into the game
thank you yeah let's take a look okay so
first off we start off this is
environment moving coming to the pillar
of light to tell the sense of where you
are just end up where you go so why did
you guys go through the trouble of
adding this portion of the game instead
of just saying hey select your avatar
that you well we've all we've always had
that beam being a big part of the Kinect
Sports franchisees to get yourself in
the game waverers avatars on 360 and we
really wanted to show off the power of
the new sensor and so now it's candid my
body types you can see I can have a tear
and fun with it and we just wanted a
cool fun way to start the game off and
make it much more personal things the
whole thing about Kinect Sports rivals
is it's really meaningful competition
and there's nothing more meaningful than
putting yourself in the game or playing
at your friends and now we go onto the
extra cool bit which is the face game so
I'm sitting down now such as I get my
head level with the sensor and then
David's would take us through my head's
in the perfect space I've always thought
your head was in the ideal position at a
knee and then we just got a simple way
of scanning and getting more - since we
go
you're nearly there tilt your head down
to finish that's it question quite clear
quite simple nice I have to say I'm kind
of fond of the terrifying pixel monster
on screen right now
I almost wish I could play as that in
the main game yeah so this was just a
fun thing this is what we call face your
I've a Tyrian so I think change my
expression
open my mouth we have little Easter eggs
as well I'll put my hands over my ears
the sound goes down there's a few others
in there oh I'm just a fun way again to
get into the game keep it fun and
charmese I know you all right if we
could be not bad yeah just straight
other books and so maybe the beards a
bit heavy but the thing this is a great
sign 2016 looks a lot like me no I wish
I looked a little bit like that but we
also have a large number of
customization features so if you I'm not
quite happy with what you've got what
you want to express yourself in slightly
different way so for example hey there I
want to give myself for a bit of a shave
I can just pop in we populate with all
the different vendors to textures you
can see lots of different beard science
but you can just take that down a bit
oh there you go and there we go
perfectly so let's give a little bit of
context here out of all the supports
that we could choose why are we taking a
look at bowling right now well this is
one of our fan favorites everyone love
bowling on the previous connect sport
series but what we wanted to show here
is some of the fidelity that we can get
from the Newton so I'm able to do things
that we weren't able to do before this
is the environment we're into rather
than just a boring old bowling alley we
actually take
bowling and from flexibles rivals on the
boat so we worship in the harbour we
have two environments of Stone Forest
and the harbour area we have a number of
AA sports from wake racing or we observe
climbing so cool in here so I'll just
put my hand up to engage and the cool
thing is with the fidelity of the sensor
now as you can see I can open and close
my hand and I counter mimics that so
wanted to do is just reach out and grab
a ball and that's something that the
previous generation Connect wasn't able
to do their fine skeletal movement yeah
we just didn't have just didn't have the
fidelity that we do
oh nice that one is skirts upon it and
stored money but it's kind of great
because it really allows us to start
adding some really interesting mechanics
for the gameplay it is it actually able
to tell when you've like let go of the
ball yep oh that's not to do that so
I'll show you some show you a couple of
things so here's the clown flower plane
which we care about it yeah my second
line so he's at the same level to me
sort out at my counter quite a long
other things we can do get it it's a
little bit tricky there you go it's
always been there
that's okay because you do have an ace
up your sleeve with that overhand shot
you showed me earlier yeah so that's the
cool thing with the the release having a
good you can't do lots of crazy shots
and have fun with it
bombing so I guess I ultimate party
language so we support four players so
you can put four champions in here well
of course
let's give me how's chameleon give us to
have been here we go let's do this and
see if we can get it
overhand left handed over handle it
firmly that's the kind of stuff that
gets you kicked out of a real bowling
and yeah well this is the kind of fun we
can happen so I guess the only other
thing is you looking to the environment
itself as said you see all the other
crowd around sometimes you'll see birds
flying around and stuff in helicopters
going past and those sort of things so
and it's all done in 1080p so you know
these really rich beautiful environments
which should take part in whether that's
bowling here on the ship we have tenants
on this massive rock stacked a like
hundreds of feet above the ground it's a
wake tracing around the harbor area
soccer which is in the boat as well
target shooting and ultimately climbing
where you're doing that on the rock sack
and a hanging ship was just really
really our dad well thanks for this
little showcase of the new Kinect tech
here when is Kinect Sports rivals gonna
be out in stores connect spokesmodels
will be out in stores on April the 8th
there in the US so go out and get it and
have a great day
all right thanks a lot thank you
you